a silent prayer for a life lost of his
eight children may meet kvick says his
son Ibrahim was his favorite three
months ago ebrahims body was returned
from Syria the 26 year old died while
fighting for the Kurdish resistance he
was helpful and he cared a great deal
for his people we have relatives in the
Kurdish part of Syria he wanted to take
up arms to protect them from the enemy
Ibrahim kvick lived in on Bernice on a
small Kurdish town near the
turkish-syrian border he ran a food shop
here now his older brother has taken
over the shop Ibrahim had always dreamed
of a Kurdish revolution one day he
decided to take action under the name
air doll he spent eight months fighting
for Kurdish autonomy on Syrian soil
before he left he wrote off his
customers debts put things in order and
closed the shop then he was gone none of
us knew about his plans but we respect
his decision as Kurds we are repressed
and attacked everywhere not only in
Syria but in Iraq Iran and Turkey we
have to defend ourselves metaphor that
Matthew
whether they join the ranks of Kurdish
fighters taking up arms against Islamic
state forces in Syria or the militant
Kurdish Workers Party fighting on home
soil many young Kurds see violent
conflict as their only escape from
poverty and discrimination the PKK flag
has become a common sight that the
funerals of Kurds killed in fighting in
Syria many don't differentiate between
the Turkish government and Islamic state
terrorists two years ago the Turkish
government and the PKK agreed on a
ceasefire based on the principle of
peace in return for reforms but the
Kurdish Peace and Democracy party is
disappointed with the government's
concessions we don't want a new civil
war we suffered under that for 40 years
for just allowing us to speak our own
language is not enough we want
recognition of our culture and you want
autonomy if we're to prevent our boys
from taking up arms will have to take
serious steps in that direction what are
the madam Altimus yet eq but the PKK is
calling for a return to violence across
the region and the call is being heard
close to the Syrian border we meet Ahmad
a turkish kurd the young medical student
left his hometown of adana to join the
fight for Kurdistan how and where he
doesn't yet know but he's sure that
relying on peaceful means is not the
answer the Turkish nationalists continue
to humiliate us by saying there is only
one nationality and one language the
peace talks have taken us nowhere so at
least if we join an armed struggle we
can demonstrate our pride in our roots
and it gives us a space to live in
freedom someone on the other marching
when a police car drives past Ahmad
makes a run for it by now he will be in
the mountains with the PKK it was this
dream of freedom and a better life that
drew Ibrahim kuvak to join the Kurdish
armed resistance movement before he left
he wrote a goodbye letter to his brother
there is so much injustice I refuse to
accept I don't just mean what we as
Kurds are made to suffer but also other
people and groups around the world he
lost his life for his belief in justice